so annie i heard there was something you
wanted to tell us about right now
um it's a dildo oh my gosh what about
the dildo
i got it from adam and eve i heard
they're the number one trusted source
for adult toys
in my house they are so i have a whole
artillery of toys from adam and eve it's
a very important part
of my healthy sex life i like that
there's 24 7 customer support
for those customers that need a little
extra help like maybe me
90 day no hassle returns and of course
discreet packaging in case you're
living in your parents basement like i
just did for the last two weeks
and 20 of the profits go to help fight
the spread of hiv around the world
2021 is adam and eve's 50th anniversary
you guys can visit adamandeve.com and
use code blood for 50
off one item and free shipping in the us
and canada some exclusions apply again
visit adamandeve.com and use code blood
for 50 off one item and free shipping in
the us
and canada what should they try
i just listen i don't need much i just
need one vibrator
with maybe 50 different settings
that's it is that true though yeah like
a swiss army knife
you know yeah i i'm a very simple gal as
well
i like things that are compact yeah i
like things that are a little bit more
discreet
but i like i don't i like medium power
yeah medium is a good level you don't
want light
i go full blast out of the gate
720 horsepower how can you be ready for
that i'm like
i feel like when you go straight forward
i'm like like i need
a you want your dildo to give you
foreplay
i've never had a dildo have you well i
just think you can call them all dildos
i had a dildo and it was it was like a
suction cup dildo and i was like i guess
you're supposed to like
suction cup into the wall and bang the
wall but it's like how do you look
yourself you just back up into it right
you back up into it that's very
performative that's like for someone
else
watching and are you sure it's the wall
or not the floor i mean you could do the
floor
i mean you do your asian squats yeah
that's a very easy i don't have the
pelvis of a philippines
i have a filipino of a filler
i'm so hot but my arms are so fat what
do i do
what do i do what do i do it's so hot
i'm so sweaty i'm so comfortable so
whitney listen i was in whitney's pool
she took all these videos she's like can
i post these and i was like whitney
if you post these i will [ __ ] you
will be dead you'll be floating in that
pool by the end of the day
it's i just listen i've been on
quarantine i've been having a good time
it's all good but and you can i feel
good right and i think i hold my weight
proportionately i did weigh myself and i
went
okay i'm no longer even in oscar de la
hoya's weight
i lose she's in a lower weight class
than i am at this point are you a welter
now
i i'm i i'm i think i'm a sumo at this
point
it's very large and i'm like wow that
number doesn't match up
with what i see and feel but then when
you get a when you get a sunlit
video next to someone who's got a
perfect body
i mean i i don't i know this is a scary
this is the worst word i could say to
esther in our friendship
i started a fast a cleanse a cleanse not
a fast
esther gets scared when i do these i'm
very anti
i'm doing cleanse fasts it's out of
focus what cleanse are you doing
it's called well i don't want to give
them a thing because i just randomly
bought it but it just was one thing i
bought
randomly what now that
hold up put my tampon in here
um i just had one smoothie so far well i
knew that maybe you were
thinking about doing a cleanse because
she sent me this thing on instagram she
was like look at this
amazing natural beauty and it she
thought that it was a video of
a 65 year old woman in bali
doing some type of like skin thing where
she was how to get rid of your frown
lines and it was a video of this like
wellness coach
i was like oh my god she's aging
gracefully she's not getting botox look
at this and she's massaging her frown
lines like this remember that annie
and then i immediately i was like no i
guarantee you that woman is younger than
us
and sure enough she was like 34
35 and apparently she she had gone
listen to this esther she's famous
because she went on
a year-long dry fast basically
zero water why did she do that
and she says that oh all the you know um
the juices from like fruits coconut
water
water are far more like valuable to the
body than just plain water
i was in shock because i said i'm
literally getting thirsty hearing this
i'm like
i need to drink drinks i'm so thirsty
she's like this is my fruit juice it's a
peach snapple
it's really good though actually who am
i kidding there's no sugar in it it
sucks
it kind of sounds like your baked goods
that you made
i was like did she make salt instead of
what is this
you [ __ ] i sat there and i ate it all
and pretended i liked it though
i want to try your vegan cookies esther
you thank you
you can i i would rather you be like
this sucks in the moment
i know i forgot who you were as a person
but here how about annie since she's in
the fast the best way to have people
like something
is to give it to them when they're
deprived so i guarantee you if you make
the same thing
when she's on a third day of fasting
it's not as fast as a cleanse i'm having
like smoothies but that is a fun fact
i want to use that on myself to like
i'll be really hungry and then i'll try
like shrimp or something i don't want it
you should get cinnamon toast shrimp no
i don't know what what
what is gross to you that you wouldn't
want i oh i guess i could have crickets
everybody's mad at me
look you guys i went down sorry i didn't
want crickets yeah
were you cricket shamed i i everybody's
mad at me that i didn't want to eat the
crickets and
i'm scared of bugs four four comments
even though they live on her hair
there were four comments and underneath
were like 70 comments of other people
being like we love her what are you
talking about let her be
i'm afraid of bugs okay sorry that's
like my evolutionary history where i'm
afraid of bugs well you don't want to
eat
my grandma what you don't want to eat
your own
okay anything that i'm challenged to do
i will probably do i can't say that
what i love that about you you're the
only one who would stood the durian
challenge and that's
my people and i failed it was the most
disgusting thing that's one thing i
won't eat esther ever again it's julian
ever i won't even have it near my house
that was wrong oh that's a bummer
because i did bring some here today
i pop it off it wasn't a tampon the
whole time it was durian
have you guys ever watched porn with a
lover i mean
of course yeah i don't like doing that
why don't you like it yeah
i just don't like to i don't know we're
there i don't need to have another
couple there
i i do feel like it's a little dated
what do you mean
i like that was the cool thing like
eight years ago
no in the 90s maybe we're in high school
we were like
let's watch a porn together let's rev
our engines simultaneously
but i don't feel as though like i would
rather he watch
his own on his phone i watch my own on
my phone because we have different
preferences
or are you like going are you is there a
double-headed dildo in between your
buttholes and you're going
outward where are you bobby and i go ask
to ask
just like a dream that's that's that's
our style or do you go like you go watch
your porns and then you meet up you're
like let's meet up in like 20.
yeah i'd rather do that because my
preferences are
so different the stuff that i like to
watch could possibly turn them off
what ah forgive me jesus but i
am into um cream pie gang bangs
like i like one woman strapped down and
ten guys
cream pie in her in a competition to see
who impregnates her
that's what i'm into i accidentally
creampied today
well first of all i have to i have to
come clean with the way i bang now
i have this is like an ester i'm really
i want to give this to you because i
feel like
with your effort level you'll enjoy this
but i have
i call it like i call it a geriatric
bang what it is is
you take like i have a hospital bed like
an old people bed where you can like
you can lift up the bottom or the or the
back so i
hoist on the the edge of it and todd
controls the remote and lifts me up my
vagina up to it with a remote yes
and it's like and then i'm there but so
it's a slow bang
that's a very slow balance it's not like
that's not the movements i mean the move
okay but that's just to get the
positioning
yeah and then um when we're done i am
almost like if he's not holding on to me
i will fall backwards because i'm
straight up in the air
so as i'm rolling back some of it goes
into my butthole
oh i had an accidental cream pie wait
wait
you're wait wait i'm just going in you
yeah i'm on my period he's going in you
yeah i'm on my period
you know what i'll be real i tell
everyone connoisseur be safe i tell my
niece that
but yeah i'm a [ __ ] queen
also my sister-in-law is watching this
but we've been and my mom is watching
but
wait are you on birth control i was for
a really really long time in fact i got
pregnant on birth control
oh this is that's how big the cream pie
was
are you're off at now yeah i'm off it
now what does that mean are you
the pregnancy she's off the pregnancy
are you i just know my days i don't i
don't um participate
in um adventurous coitus during my
ovulation
cycle how do you know is it the someone
said you can tell by the
by the stuff that comes out of this i'm
very i don't know like bobby is not
he doesn't have projectile sperm he's
more like a small a light dribbler none
of us are surprised
yeah he has no like torque like oh
you're saying his sperm doesn't go on
sprints and run
or it just kind of you know poop it does
that
um so it's hard to tell but i will say
that as he's getting older he's
complained about a leaky dick
which means that he has more like
pre-comb than normal
which is why i really really am careful
during my
um you know obviously yeah my hot eggs
day
or my hot eggs week and how do you track
it i have a eve
sponsor sponsor us i've been using the
period tracker
app you don't ever just like scoop in
and then play with your fingers and see
what
you would do that to me i feel like well
she was like do you want me to try if
you were not on youtube every once in a
while you have like you have rubber glue
pause if you were not on your period pro
i would scoop into your vagina and tell
you what part of your cycle you're on
i like that i'm not on my period esther
wait only fans guys only fans stop only
fans
oh my god really sad
that you only offered annie i would much
rather do it to you
i honestly i don't want to like be a
fomo person but i feel like you have to
do it to both of us at the same time
do you think oh my gosh we have to is
this for only
yeah yeah 100 i'll gladly give you my
[ __ ] no problem oh my god like
i'm getting that [ __ ] she gets the
[ __ ] i want to scoop in there and see
if i can tell
what part of your cycle you're on yeah
climb on board
ovulating is really a dangerous game for
me because i find
everyone hot when i'm ovulating everyone
is [ __ ] and attractive
like the taxi driver is absolutely
on on the menu so your birth control as
you know when you want to [ __ ] you can't
maybe you're right i just am really bad
at tracking that stuff but i do know
what you're talking about like there's
definitely times where
you're more in the in the zone yeah i
specifically
planned girls weekends when i'm on the
week of my period when i'm really fat
and bloated so there's just no chance my
self-esteem is very good that week
i know i'm so low self-esteem right now
are you on your period
i'm on my period i just can't believe he
went go-go in you
he does go go go it's a not a no-no
to go go-go i go go in you
cuz i because i know you're so afraid of
a pregnancy
right that's why i let him do it when
i'm on my period but that's not that's
like a myth
you can still still get pregnant for
sure you're like we'll see
roll that dice ani i don't think you
should be going go go on you
without you there
[Laughter]
okay esther yes to exhume the
grandparents it's a big thing i want to
hear from you
okay so i went to my parents house last
week
and you know whenever i'm there i was
i'm very curious about my grandparents
who passed away before i was born
because i'm their only grandchild you
know my dad was an only child
and they were they had just written off
that he would never have kids and you
know they passed away
and you know my dad will sometimes like
tell me little things about how much
they would have loved me and like
how you know how i missed out on like
all the relatives and family stuff so
this has like really affected me like
ever since
like i was lit i would like stay up at
night crying like thinking about and i
was also raised in their house
um and i have none of their belongings
inside their urn
it was really weird very tight in there
but she's tiny they work today
i have none of their belongings because
when my grandmother passed away my dad
was like oh well i'm never having kids
and i don't need this stuff so he gave
everything away and like she had some
she had like a rolex like he just gave
it all away
was like who's who needs this and so i
have this like and again like
just wanting their stuff is pretty like
you realize like oh well that's not
gonna bring them back
like it's not nothing is going to cure
this like deep sadness i have from never
knowing my only grandparents that would
have loved me because my other
grandparents is
complicated um maybe you should take the
hint from that one that the other ones
wouldn't have yeah
those ones know me and they don't like
me so i'm just kind of putting a lot of
eggs in the basket of the ones that
don't know how
you do have like them your grandparents
that's annoying it's like how dare you
not like
you do have a living set of grandparents
then my mom's parents so i know my
grandma and she's pretty much
done with my [ __ ] uh and
my i have a gran my grandfather passed
away about four years ago and that was
my mom's stepdad but like he was my
grandpa for all
was it like right before you were gonna
visit he's like it's time
and uh my i met my biological
grandfather once he was in a trailer
park he has a tattoo of a naked woman
i'm
halfway trash i popped out of a tuna can
um what did you think of him i was
convicted when i was
just confused i was like what is this is
he still alive can we go see him
my mom claims he's still alive but we
haven't heard like she says that if he
died we would know but she hasn't spoken
to him since we saw him whatever 25
years ago
20 years ago those are dudes with the
best stories i don't know i'm not
interested
we like don't like him right he's like a
bad
what because there's a naked lady no if
you were a tattoo person there would be
so many naked ladies on your body by the
way
no we don't like him because he's like
we love the our
our real grandpa who you have both
really yeah
my mom my mom is adopted and she never
met her family because she didn't want
to make
her parents feel but i don't think her
adopted parents would have cared
i think that was like she was worried
about that there's enough
yeah there's enough love to go around i
think i'll have to talk to my mom but i
don't i don't know that's like a weird
vibe but yeah i
in theory i have a biological
grandfather alive who probably has no
idea who i am and doesn't give a [ __ ]
that's so exciting that's right a lot of
people don't
like a storyline undiscovered
like you don't know like what if there
are parts of you
where you're like oh my god what if he's
like really hot and cold at the same
time and like hungry
and wants things yeah like from a
genetic standpoint like i'm that's where
my curiosity would be like yeah
you see parts of like yourself in them
something tells me those characteristics
are from the jewish side
but anyways so all that i have my
grandparents
is where they're buried and it just got
me thinking like
what were they buried with like i don't
even know is there anything
in there that like is a memento and
like a treasure map like what are you
looking for like
and adam and eve they were around 50
years ago a dress
or like uh but you would take the dress
that the corpse is in and take it for
yourself if there was something
in there she would take the corpse let's
be real you're not leaving the corpse
esther
first of all is it i'm curious is it
legally if i'm next of kin
is it legal for me to exhume um i
i'm the wrong person to ask because i in
the philippines it's like
the wild wild west and we just exhumed
our um
one of my uncles because we couldn't pay
for the um plot anymore with my family
there couldn't pay for the plot
so they were like oh let's just move him
to the backyard and so they exhumed him
and um it was it became like a whole
family drama and
wait what don't you have to pay it up
front
oh no what it was is they were selling
the plot they needed money
for money wow the plot because the plot
was a real it's a really
nice nice um area it's a very like uh
it's kind of like that rolling hills
right here
on the freeway of the five yeah the
fourth it's really pretty before
i feel like forest lawn is they have
their own
street that's like if you're buried
there it's you're pretty much famous
it's really yes there it's probably it's
probably very expensive
my dad is actually he has his dad left
him a bunch of graves and my dad's
currently trying to sell them so 21 in
the chicago
area is looking to buy some grapes
dm me um you should find another short
person to and you can split one grave
save your money but so i don't know i
just had me curious if i could legally
even exhume them
and if i could would i to see what's in
there but my dad has claimed that that
there's nothing there
like that they were just buried in their
clothes like he he wouldn't bury them
with julie but my dad doesn't
remember anything and i know he was very
you know traumatized during it
so he could have put i think there's a
chance my dad could have put some
mementos in there
or the wrong person yep but what is it
so disoriented
[Applause]
we open it up it looks like bobby like
oh my god but i again i'm chasing
something that's not there right like i
just want any piece of them like i
and i no no no i've done ayahuasca
you're chasing something that is there
but it's in there
you're looking for something outside of
you but it's actually in you your
grandparents
all of our relatives are in living in us
through our veins
so your grandfather that lives in the
trailer park the trailer park
you can avoid him if you want but annie
and i are meeting him
i'm actually very attracted to him
already trailer park he's making lady
tattoos i'm still younger than her
dad still everyone's younger than my dad
joe biden is still younger than my dad
you guys let's talk about a little
company that we love have you guys heard
of adam and eve have you heard about
we are ribs i was eating ribs last night
and i was thinking i love the story of
adam and eve and then
i got horny and i went and i got my own
adam and eve product
yes they've been around for 50 years you
guys know that that means they know what
they're doing
and they are still the number one
trusted source for adult toys
it's pretty cool too because they have
24 7 customer support
90 day no hassle returns and discreet
packaging i don't know about you but
those are things that i really need from
companies that i buy
intimate products from you don't want
your boyfriend to know you're getting a
deal
that's mine well also i like the 24 hour
a day
service because who's banging between
like
office hours you need late nights to
help visit
adamandeve.com and use the code blood
b-l-o-o-d for 50
off one item plus free shipping in the
us and canada
some exclusions apply again visit
adamandeve.com
and use the code blood for 50 off
one item and free shipping in the us and
canada honestly if you're listening to
this episode
which you are you might need one of
these like right now
yeah it gets crazy hot and heavy
about the jewelry stuff aren't you
afraid of like cursed items like i'm
always afraid to like take things that
um belong to the past the past sometimes
they need to be buried with that like
you don't know what happened when
because my my grandmother on my dad's
side is buried in tunisia
and um word on the street is she was
she was buried with a gigantic ruby ring
like and it was um i mean we could go on
like uh
you know we could exhume her but i'm
just saying i don't want to touch that
because i
i think she lived a painful life i have
an idea
like she deserves to like die without
red jewel
i have an idea i think we should make a
treasure map to your grandmother's grave
indonesia yes and we should um
we'll do we'll release some riddles each
week on only fans
and if you guys can put it together dig
it up it's yours
it'll be on the show here's another clue
we have apparently it's near
sophia lorenz old vacation home well
let's go
is this this is the philippines no no
indonesia okay so we're going to start
with your grandpa
okay that's that's our first point of
our treasure quest
to your point i feel so much ownership
over my grandparents that i felt i
really believe in my heart that if they
had something down there they'd want me
to have it
and that my friends is called
entitlement
would you would you wear the dress on
the show if i yes i would i don't
i wonder what it is because she was old
you know so it's not like
i feel like i wore it on her birthday
episode could you deal with that though
like looking at
um like bones in the soil like are you
okay with that stuff
yeah it does feel i went to my i was my
grandparents are
buried in connecticut and i was doing a
weekend in hartford
i don't know three years ago my mom was
like oh your grandparents are brave so i
went to the
and i i went to the graves and it was
unbelievable it was so amazing and there
my mom was adopted so it wasn't blood
but it did still feel that same way
and i was so like i was so moved i
missed my grandfather it was so good to
see him and then the groundskeeper
was just like walking around and i was
and i just started talking to him as i
do talk to everyone
usually anyone creepy enough to look
like they're walking around a grave
gravesite i will be talking
to i recently had an encounter with the
groundskeeper too but keep going
he knew my grandfather i told him who i
was and he goes i know your grandfather
because
like the lineage of the family had been
buried there and he had come in and
would go visit them and stuff and
he has like my grandfather's writing in
a log he
opened it and i was like how [ __ ]
incredible how did he have that
because that's what they do they just do
he had like a whole like log and my
grandfather came in and would like sign
it
and he had all this stuff written out
like my grandfather's wishes and stuff
it was awesome
now have you never met your biological
grandparents your mom's
my mom never looked for them or anything
my mom was what she knows about her
birth parents was that her mother was
like in co like art school or something
like a young artist
so you have lost grandparents too what
was the name of your grandparents do you
know
her she's abigail but her name was
marnice gleesner
if she on her birth certificate marnies
she would be named marnice
gleasner why did do you know does she or
you know why she was put up for adoption
because her mom was young and i think
she wasn't with the dad
[Music]
wow but and it's cool because my mom's a
really good artist and then i'm a good
artist it's like interesting and but my
brothers and my dad
are bad artists you are a good artist i
have a feeling your experience with the
groundskeeper was very different from
annie's
it was it was when we were filming he
thought you got out he was like oh my
god
he was like there's an empty grave get
back in i get in
okay sorry good night
i was when we were filming alone
together and
we shot a scene at hollywood forever
cemetery love that place
and me too it's so beautiful awesome and
uh
there was a groundskeeper and we had
like time in between because we were
waiting for it to get dark
and like i was just a young hollywood
starlet and he was
but a groundskeeper and i hopped on his
golf cart and he showed me around and
took me on a tour and judy garland had
just been
exhumed and moved to hollywood forever
from new jersey because i guess liza
minnelli like wanted the family to all
be together so
he was like only families let in but
i'll let you in and he took me into her
little cove
um and we just wow there was there you
said you weren't molested
there was a vibe if he just drove you
off of the
he drove us into the water i have a
question for you kalila
because you're a nurse you want not
anymore can we stop saying that
you're a working nurse i'm not i
couldn't even get the vaccine early
that's how
on nurse i am um
and i get squeamish very easily i was
very squeamish
when annie pierce re-pierced her nipples
and you're not you were into it
is there anything that grosses you out
or makes you squeamish
after all your nurse experiences or
anything still that yeah
what i have i don't like the smell of
this thing called
c diff and it's a hospital acquired
kind of diarrhea and it's
it's you will not miss it you walk in
and you're like
that see this it only smells like one
thing it's uh
you get uh intractable diarrhea from it
and
um is that when it goes in what's
intractable intractable means like you
just [ __ ] you can't stop
like it just keeps flowing out of you
what you had the other day
pasta um
that so that thing i will it smells
almost like i think that's why i was so
sensitive to durian because it kind of
like smelled like that
plus toe jam plush [ __ ] plus all the
nasty things like put together i can't
do c diff
um it's a type of diarrhea it's a type
of diet um yeah it's a type of
bacteria that gets into your guts
usually passed on from like
hospital patient to hospital patients
especially if they've been there a long
time another thing is i'm not good with
phlegm
oh no flum is not my thing you throw up
yeah like even especially when you like
when it's a trick patient then you have
to do like the suction and stuff
that's really rough for me yeah you get
used to it eventually but it's not fun
is there something that's really gross
to most people that you're completely
comfortable with
i think i'm just comfortable with
everything besides those two i think i
don't what about you
i don't like watching like surgeries and
stuff on
i don't like that like dr dr pimple
popper like oh
it's a cutting situation for me like
it's suffering like sour candy
yeah it's like why am i but there's
nothing sweet at the end of it there's
no
i'm not like happy when it's over i'm
horrified i do think it's a good diet
plan if you just eat your meals in front
of that show
but or this show that's true the point
i think that dr pimple popper i if it's
like
a cyst that's like gooey stuff coming
out while it doesn't gross me out it
doesn't excite me i need
the blackheads the blackheads is where
the thrill is
the d-pal when you have to work for it
and then there's the release at the end
yeah
you see how deep it was and now it's
just a giant hole in someone's body
that's a real thrill for me what if i
was like klyla
i really need to wax my [ __ ] and i
can't reach and i was like can i just
stop by
will you do it a thousand percent i'd
wax pete
and andres's [ __ ] today with
permission from their wives
there's there's very few things um what
what else there's one thing that i don't
like
oh i'll tell you what i don't like
i don't like eating [ __ ] yeah
i i've had um many experiences and i
just that's how i know
i might be yeah i might be fully
leans forward wait what are you talking
about many experiences you've never had
an adult
situation with a woman no have you tried
have you even
how do you even she can't try because
she'll have to get a divorce
you when what do you mean many many
times you've hooked up with are you mad
or you're mad that it wasn't you
are you are you bisexual no i i i
i don't i don't think you like me or not
i heard you
i already said you could scoop my my
schmeg
her snail trail my snail trail i want
you
i know
yeah i mean she's still my friend she
said i don't have friends anymore
yeah my friend and i went to this
actually is one of my favorite stories
me too i used to tell her name and then
she was like why are you
i was like she was like thought she
wouldn't care
she was like um she's a famous comedian
we were we had just both moved here from
new york
um she grew up here and we were both
having a similar situation with dating
guys where we couldn't
get we would go on dates with guys or
like go on a couple dates with them and
they would give us that sort of like
you want something more serious than we
want and we're like what are you talking
about we're busy we're like really
killing it in comedy we're not like
trying to have a relationship
we're trying to [ __ ] but they like
wouldn't [ __ ] us because they thought we
were trying to like
date them or something we were just
having the same experience so we're like
you know what [ __ ] this we're gonna go
to venice one night there's santa monica
we're just gonna pick up some surfers
and we're just going to like bang some
surfers or some skaters
and just and we're going to so we were
happy
we were having we're having a sleepover
in her like high school room
at her parents house where she was
parents house yeah
you're trying to just make me jealous
yeah at this point you're really yeah
tie-dyed sweatpants and it was
cool clayton did our hair and um
no but so okay so we were like we're
just gonna go out and we're just gonna
like find the hottest guys and we're
just gonna [ __ ] them and never talk to
them again
and we're gonna bring them back to her
house so because honestly it
is fun to i don't like watching porn
with my partners but i do
not anymore but i did for a while really
like
like that sort of high school ecology
thing where you just bang in the same
room i don't know we were just like
side by side worldwide yes my best
friends
my best friends and i like that's our
motto
am i the only person who never had a
life i've never done that you are
and you just realizing this is wild
those four comments noticed let's let's
let's say that
i would maybe you know i read the
commentary i went back
there were so few it was so funny maybe
you deserve to be crooked shamed after
all answer
i need a i need a new second childhood
you can't even take me out on the town
you need a rump rider what is it called
it's not got a rubber what's the thing
where they let you like
you know yeah you need dave needs to let
you go out
it's um when the amish when when you hit
a certain age in the amish community is
that what it is andreas
and then you have no but he's george's
best friend george
is basically homeless he looked at him
like he was full amish
wait and like you guys can't see but she
looked at andres like he was in a full
like he was on a buggy right now he was
churning butter
um but that's george grew up lds you
know so he wasn't allowed to
well he wasn't lds he was um i'm sorry
he was um
a seven-day adventist and so he wasn't
allowed coffee wasn't allowed to dance
wasn't what he wanted to eat he does
scream i've never danced no
we'll say that about george there's
something about him not allowed to dance
so so yeah when you're what would you
have been you weren't allowed to tour
wait esther maybe we should give you a
rum springer yeah
ask dave if if this is doable because in
the amish community you have i think one
year is it or is it three months i'm not
sure where you can just go
hog wild [ __ ] anything like you could be
on girls gone wild like yeah
you really could there's a show about it
and then you can come back
if you want and after you come back to
the community because you've gotten out
all your
your temptations are all now um um
lived out but god you come back to that
community with
every std think about that you're just
like
bringing it to the to the village your
pet crabs wait
there it is rum springer rum springer
rum springer
is a rite of passage during adolescence
translated in english as jumping
hopping around used in amish communities
it used to be called a rum springer but
then we had to
um annie can you finish your story about
your surfer dudes
okay so then esther needs to finish
she needs me to finish so she can finish
so we go out and we literally were i
mean we were we looked gorgeous
it was just such a win night like it was
just gonna happen so well
and so we go to the first we went to
like a wine bar first which
we thought was a mistake and maybe it
was maybe we should have gone to like
this shitty like
dive bar first but we went to the wine
bar first and there were these guys that
were like good looking but they looked
like they had jobs and they had like
boring you know like they just like
god's
jobs aren't as good and bad certainly
yeah they certainly are industry no you
gotta
the best i gotta go for broke baby there
was this guy the best sex i had
um when i was like you know sport
[ __ ]
was um was this guy we called homeless
julian in santa fe because he was so
he wasn't homeless but he was do you
know what i mean he did have a place but
he's just like
um but he yeah he i used to say he
[ __ ] me like i was gonna make him a
sandwich you know
i was gonna buy him a meal he had a
he had like this monster truck with no
doors on it and he would take me he
caught it romping
he would take me like into the arroyo
and we would just you put the seatbelt
on you just like be going like straight
down straight up
that sounds romantic and then yeah we
made out on the top but no he gave me
bacterial vaginosis
that's not romantic yeah yeah that's a
bad smell
but bv it was really bad i went down on
a girl with bv and i think that's why
i'll never eat [ __ ] again i could have
just stayed a lesbian
yeah it's not it's not fun guys and then
she was just so rude and unaware and
granted we were all drunk but
the smell um stuck to my nose hairs for
about two weeks
and i i think that's when i decided that
i would never
go down i would never have sexual
relations with uh with women ever again
and it's it's really not women's fault
it was her fault she could have been
like hey
she could have honked her horn yeah i
said hey uh the the jingies is happening
there is i mean obviously like dicks
have smoked feminine the jingies
doesn't know how they call it in movies
american movies what
yeah that's how i learned like i was
watching white people in mexico
but that's how i learned to say it um
from american television it's like if
stuff stuff's not feeling up to par down
there you just say oh i have the jingies
i heard it from a movie i think it was
scary movie
that was a parody movie well you know
what it taught me all i know about
america
that makes so much sense why this
podcast is disgusting
yeah we were all raised by like the
wrong things
oh hang on andy and so what happened
okay
the guys were handsome but we we got
cocky we're like we can do better
could we not okay so now we go to the
next bar
and it's too late we're there it's like
last call is
approaching us by the way i'm completely
sober in this
like she's drinking but she's not wasted
but she's drinking
i'm dead sober i had already quit
drinking like there was no
liquid courage to get me through this
okay but we had made a deal
did you have the jingies or not i didn't
have the dejengies
the next day maybe anyway so we go
we go to the next bar and this guy comes
up to me i had moved from new york i
used to do a comedy show at the
restaurant i worked at this place called
life cafe that no longer
is in business because everything i've
ever been involved with goes out of
business
watch out bloodbath my college
everything
but so i used to do a show there and um
like every friday or every thursday or
something and
randomly but that had been like five or
six years before i even maybe four years
before i moved to lm
this guy this kid comes up to me who's
not that hot
comes up to me and he goes um oh my god
i saw your show
i've come to your show before in new
york years ago oh whoa
and i was like we've got a fan and this
was like
this was huge okay because i counted
them on my hand that i can't do is [ __ ]
someone who
knows me from something oh it's got to
be
okay go ahead but they no you can why
because they like respect you too much
um i'd just be like this guy knows
like everything about me like there was
a thrill i wanted i want someone where i
can tell him who i am
and lie about it he'll find out that my
name is
yeah you know yeah like my name is
anastasia
yeah that's exactly i think that's how i
want i don't i don't say my real name at
the club
give your nail name at the club but go
ahead go ahead i mean
is that just so they can hear what your
name is it's probably hard in a club to
explain kalila to people
oh i don't i don't say my name at the
club my name's jess
yeah something release now michelle i um
okay so i so
he starts talking to me and then his
friend starts talking to our our other
friend
and they're like talking and he's like
they're they're fine they're not ugly or
anything but the other guys were like
kind of statuesque and we really blew it
we just really were i don't know the
wine bar you mean yes i don't know why
they were like
these hot like super hot guys anyway so
these
these guys were fun they're funny
they're cool they're hanging out and
just by the other night we're like i
guess these are our guys you know
it wasn't like what we had gone out to
do but we you know we were doing it
so um so we take them back to her place
and pull her mattress off so like she
has like
her there's like an extra mattress so
there's a mattress on the floor for me
and her guy i think her dad was
saw us walk into i'm pretty sure her dad
was like smoking weed in the front
but um so we go in into her room
and me and my guy were taking our shirts
off we're like starting to make out
and then her guy freaks out it's four in
the morning at this point and her guy
like sits up and he goes
i have an emergency i have to go and i'm
like that emergency had to have been a
tiny penis like he probably
just like didn't think there was gonna
be that many people there right he was
like i've gotta go and he just like runs
off
too much of an audience right yeah so he
runs off and then
we're all just like partially undressed
so we're just like i guess we should all
just like
and he was just the friend of the guy
like it really was just like
so but and he knew me which kind of
defeated the purpose already of this
anonymous night but yeah
we end up like going on her bed and
i'm really not like i go i used to do a
bit about this because i was like you
can tell who's the better friend by who
says what so i go
i'm like okay i'll like i'll go down on
you while you go down on her yeah
like that's really nice right and then
um but then you're just getting face
[ __ ]
no but then she what she says she goes
come all over her face
you guys let's talk about manscaped
do you love it i love it i love it it's
trusted by over 2 million men worldwide
so why not trust it for your man too
it's a great gift idea it's below the
waist grooming and hygiene
and they have technology that you're
gonna want
they have forever changed personal
grooming with their performance package
the performance package kit comes with
the essential lawnmower 3.0
waterproof cordless body trimmer the
weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer and a ton of
other liquid formulations
and can you bend over i want to manscape
you right now
do you want me to hold my balls forward
or
[Laughter]
you guys we love manscaped here on
bloodbath we
love the products we love this the
smells
we've all been sent a package and we
absolutely love it and we highly
recommend
and we want you guys to support the show
by supporting manscaped
and you can get 20 off plus free
shipping with the code bloodbath at
manscape.com
this is the perfect grooming gift for
any man and you guys
make this the number one thing on your
wish list oh and this is something
esther will really like
these formulations by the way are vegan
diet free
sulfate free and paraben free so you
know his manhood is in good hands
get 20 off and free shipping with a code
bloodbath at manscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com
with the code bloodbath your man will
thank you
so i just was like i could have just
been a sock like they could have 69.
there was no reason for me to be there
at all i was like what
it was like my whole idea i was like um
okay i'm done
like i don't want to do this anymore you
were just a wet towel i was the wet
towel
and then in the morning i called her and
i was like do you remember when you and
she was i was like do you remember when
you just told him to come on my face she
was
lost or should she laugh for like an
hour it was so funny like
there's not another way i would have
wanted this to go but anyway so then
so then obviously like he's texting the
next day and i'm like block block [ __ ]
like bro it's done like
you're never talking to us again so what
was he saying i don't i think you want
to hang out
and it was like we're never hanging out
again like this is a wrap
like i will run from you if i see you
again i would do everything in my power
to erase you from my mind so i don't
recognize you and if i do
you'll never so then i don't hear from
him block him on everything don't hear
from him for a year
all of a sudden i'm on my way's app my
[ __ ] driving directions app
and for some reason i didn't even
realize you could request people to be
your friend
i got a request to be friends with this
guy and i was like why would i want you
to know where i
why like you're the last person i want
to know where i am in traffic
so like i'm stuck in a traffic jam and
then he rolls up next to me roses went
down just jizzes in my face one more
time
like oh annie but it was so funny yeah
it was
i mean that's that's a sad one i mean
it's a fun one until the very end
did you do anything like my brother's
gonna watch this did you do anything
with her
no we i think we kissed a little i i
heard that they're
just curious no but when you made a
specific face
no i'm just curious what would you have
done with her i don't know
i'm first of all i'm not like attracted
to my friends
yeah me neither but wait wait you're not
here
[Music]
i'm just curious i wouldn't want to like
make out with my friends
how are you asking me i don't know do
you guys what did you guys think
unless they're into it making out is so
it doesn't mean anything like i don't
know
it's just it's just that's good to know
it just doesn't it's like it's so a
nothing thing
but i just didn't um yeah i was like i
don't want to finger my friend
i just had no interest like when we
kissed i was like all right let's just
that's why i don't understand why you
guys had a threesome
it was supposed to be a foursome um
poor guy i mean look i had a threesome
with my friend
that i worked with at abercrombie at the
glendale galleria
and we both had sex with a friend of
mine who had
who had just come out of the military he
was stationed for a long time
and um it was um really sad because she
like threw up all over his dick because
she was really drunk
but then she took a break and went and
he was drunk and she went back she
didn't even like bother wiping his dick
went by
it was it was really just a traumatic
experience um
and yeah annie's uh threesome story i
think
um is as good as it's gonna get because
all my ones
are just horrible i feel well they're
never that good it's not
it's not natural yeah i don't think
unless you're in a weird throughput i
don't know
i was in a throuple i had two guys i was
in their relationship with for years
together all three of you
yeah we were in like a relationship i
had sex with two guys all the time for
years we lived together
what is this called this yeah they call
the relationship mud bath
i'm weird like i love the attention from
one guy and i just can't believe you
were getting it from
two it was in your whole life
in that regard it was really the best it
was a lot
it's a lot when you take the sex out
like emotionally
you're now in an emotional relationship
with two people which is a lot
what does bobby think of all this he
couldn't shut up about it like when i
first told him when we first got
together that's all he did like on his
all his podcast rounds
he's like i'm dating a chick she needs
two dicks to come that's all he said
like that was his um that was his
material i was his material
the first couple months that we were
doing what he said no
i had a breeze a light breeze can make
me come i'm very easy
i'm very easy
[Laughter]
esther's finally had an adult lesbian
experience
esther now do that while you're checking
her
um this is a very sex heavy episode we
should probably switch gears i know
should i tell my brother
we were going to call my friend too
should we not call him no let's call him
wait this is the guy okay so when i was
our next-door neighbors moved in and
this boy was so [ __ ] cute like i
could not believe i'm in ambrose i look
fully i'm like in my full taylor hanson
like i look
so like a little boy and then this kid
moves in and i'm like he's so high i was
like had such a crush on him we're the
same age
and um so we just had this thing we
would like sneak out together
at that we would go meet up at the park
and make out this was like when we were
a little bit older but i had such a big
crush on him
he ended up like hooking up with one of
my friends and i was mad at him i think
there was a knife i would show through
the window or chase him with or
something
and then but i always had this huge
crush on him i thought he was so hot
and he was only there every other
weekend because his dad it was his dad's
place and his parents were divorced
and i was like wait for him to be there
and then we started being friends again
when i was like 16.
and i gave him quite a [ __ ]
one of the ways how old were you 16.
quite in a bad way
yeah why was bad about it well let's
find out we're calling him
we're calling him yeah yeah what's up
what's up all right so i was trying to
tell the [ __ ] story
my podcast and especially all day
which is also amazing you thought about
it all day oh you're welcome
um so you've been jerking off with uh
with fake teeth in your hand
um so i was trying i was starting to
talk about it and then esther goes like
was it was
why was it bad and i was like well let's
just call the source
we just went upstairs i don't even know
how we got upstairs i think we were just
going to bed
and then it just felt like you were
very still and not moving
like your head or your body well maybe
you should have [ __ ] my mouth dude
now i'm getting defensive i mean
you're my oldest friend and i feel bad
telling people this but
it was the worst [ __ ] it was like my
second or third so i'm okay with that
um i don't know just
lots of teeth
it wasn't very good well do you want
more teeth more movement
huh does anyone ever want any teeth no
no no
no teeth isn't it nothing only if it's a
light gray it's like a
no but it did i will say it did make it
it did turn us into friends
it was so bad and it ended anything
romantic between us
very much
thank you for forgiving me for that blow
job thank you matt thanks for
enlightening
i don't know about that but all right i
love you i'll call you later
oh he's so sweet my friend
my scottish friend used to call this one
girl jimmy jaws
um because she really really led she was
very tooth forward
like she couldn't i don't know if she
just had a big big mouth with big teeth
but she was
very very injurious to penises
um during blow jobs so i mean that
happened i can't imagine it was even
remotely that
i don't think it was painful i think i
was just very slow and cautious
are you on the up and up with chet hanks
no who is that consumer
um white rapper son and why do we all
why are we all giving him so much
attention what's he's hot oh really
not really but kind of he i just
movie star kids i'm just like
you if you got it all man but also he's
jamaican that's what he claims his alter
ego is jamaican
wait that's what he looks like and you
think he's hot no no no can you have can
you pull up a video of him um talking um
in pidgin
but he doesn't look like his parents no
not at all but he is theirs
because colin hanks and him are not not
at all
they don't look anything they don't look
anything alike
big up the whole island massive it's her
boy chatna
coming
do you think when um tom hanks was
um shooting joe versus the volcano he's
like one day
i'll have a son and he will be
make me so proud banana break oh these
are actually
not as bad as they usually are
[Music]
what is it it's a scorpion why do we
keep doing this to me you're making the
audience mad
you know what now you're going to get
scorpion shame that's a problem
i like scorpions i don't want to eat why
am i bullied
this is supposed to be my home my safe
space
these are for you have you ever had one
of these no
are you gonna eat those annie it's not
on my cleanse but i'll try it
are we too old to um pants or friends or
people we know so
a thing i think that's like in this day
and age sexual assault
to rip someone's clothes off of them
but in a very non-sexual way i think
it's so funny
i todd pants me weren't you on the phone
with me yeah
and you loved it you loved it it's very
fun
and i was you didn't see me it was like
my phone was
towards the tv i think you saw the
panting in a
reflection on the television and it
caught me by like a very fun surprise i
was like oh wow he just ripped her pants
off
it's the most humiliating thing someone
can do i don't know why it's so
embarrassing to me
it's just i i i find it to be the most
unacceptable thing
my best friend did me oh so dirty on our
walk we were walking
through a casino into a club in vegas
and
um i was wearing a tube top and she
only meant to pants my skirt but the
tube top got caught
in it and she pants me i didn't have a
bra or anything
and then the underwear got caught in the
skirt so she pants me
from top to bottom and i was in the
middle of the casino i i'm telling you
if you run
if you run your tapes i'm not going to
say which casino if you run your tapes
from the year
maybe what year was it maybe like 2008
you will see a very naked and shocked me
in the middle of the casino just
with my tits out and my bush out it's so
sad it's so
but it sounds a lot like my [ __ ] with
matt
but i retaliated so hard with her and i
pantsed her when she was wearing these
like
baggy jeans but with high heels i don't
know why what style she was going for at
that time
but i pantsed her her heel got
got caught in like the bottom of the
jeans and when she tried to walk
she tripped over herself and she fell
forward and like she scraped her knees
and her chin and it was the most
triumphant one of my life
but i think we should bring pantsing
back what is that oh that's the scorpion
cover should i eat it yeah
i'm guessing it's probably going to
taste just like chocolate like crunchy
like sweet and salty
give me the other ones with no chocolate
six manchurian scorpion
oh that one you can actually see the
little guys
scorpion esther you've grown so much to
being able to hold that
honestly these scare me less than the
crickets but obviously i don't want them
and i am sorry that i have a fear of
bugs
go harder they're wrong you're right you
know what i love scorpions
you guys i'm a scorpio i'd be eating
myself you wanna do it at the same time
wait do you wanna do that oh this
actually makes me kind of sad because
i i love scorpions you love scorpions no
like i love them as
animals they're kind of well they're
already dead they're not gonna come back
wait let me that's the are you
this one's chocolate mine's not okay
you're gonna do it yeah that one's
chocolate
you wanna feel it i know i feel like you
you should have this yeah you need the
crispy crispies
okay you get the real scorpion it's more
oh wait annie there's a really big one
in there
wow hi one of her no i don't i'm not
like thrilled by all these things but i
feel like i have to do it can you just
ask where are you
this is gross you out oh really
maybe we should have andres on camera it
doesn't smell good you [ __ ] eat this
you guys bought this [ __ ]
i'm gonna film is it gonna like pop on
the inside no it's gonna
just get crunchy think about it as like
a chip okay so my two co-stars are about
to
try actual crispy crusty scorpions
and yes i'm the little [ __ ] not
participating
well too bad all right ready one hold on
if i go into anaphylaxis um hospital is
not very far okay
are we doing it all at once whole thing
swallow it down are we
savoring oh i was gonna go half and then
half but you wanna take a shot i'm gonna
do the whole thing let's do the whole
thing
yeah let's just do it all right ready
one two
three
again it's like so unscorpiony there's
like no flavor
what does it taste like dude can you
feel it
it tastes like it's uh sunflower seeds
it does it's like it's kind of like it
tastes like
moth balls what's the uh consistency in
your mouth
should wear the new thing not chewy um
crunchy crunchy crispy
can you feel it's like the little pieces
of it like the tentacles
it honestly tastes like um a salt
crystal like a giant salt crystal
it doesn't taste like you do do you ever
eat sunflower seeds and just eat the
seeds yeah the whole thing
it tastes like eating the shell but it
does taste uh very stale
so it doesn't no shout out to pete or
andres because that [ __ ] was stale
where are you buying this [ __ ] you guys
need to get us fresh batches for my
girls
yeah it tastes like an old shoe this is
going to turn into esther being a weird
dictator of us like having to keep those
things
a dictator come here my girls i've got a
treat
i will be eating this banana to wash it
down
i am glad you didn't have the chocolate
yeah chocolate would have been like
nothing
well the chocolate and scorpio is just
so [ __ ] up to me on so many levels
like if you're gonna eat something like
face it look it in the eye and feel it
yeah
don't dip it in [ __ ] it's hidden in
there yeah it's like look
there's no respect for the animal
there's something slightly more
respectful
about looking an animal in the eye and
saying okay that's a thing i
killed and i'm going to eat that versus
it's plated perfectly
it's not too bad any right it tastes
like a cricket just stale taste just
like a cricket once again you guys have
failed to
disgust annie or i it's just like not
good enough it's like i wanna like what
if we loved it and that became our thing
i can't keep eating myself i love
scorpions i'm a cancer don't bring me
any of that
crabs you love crabs i do love crabs
kyle said you were shoving um crab
rangoon in your face on your ig lives oh
that was the most embarrassing i didn't
tell you this esther
what i was doing a live um
on instagram and i todd brought home
chinese food
i took like two crab rangoon and i was
like hey guys do you think i can eat it
all without biting it and was like
shoving their mouth and kyle from barry
barry's boot camp i had just commented
right as i was like
like i was a normal person and he
commented and then i was a big fat
monster pig
right as i saw his comment i was like oh
my god kyle and i had it still in my
mouth
no and then he texted me right after and
then my phone died
and then that was it i just got on
annie's live and she was stuffing her
face with crab rangoon
and he's like i could not believe my gay
eyes
it was the timing was perfect let's just
say that i love
gay men i guess i'm friends with you
i feel like we've had a really
productive day a lot of sex talk a lot
of
grave talk um i feel like this was just
another
good classic episode of bloodbath where
you really regret
sitting down with a meal esther do you
think that dave could just
give you like a hall pass for a day just
to see just to see if maybe you like
i don't think so what if it was for
ethan klein
[Laughter]
i think he would actually be so excited
to give me a hall pass for ethan klein
because then he'd be like oh she really
is attracted to me yeah that's
what she wants because he doesn't he's
like it's a lateral move yeah
what about me the guy who sings gangnam
style is that
is that my [ __ ] hall pass imagine if
that was bobby's rules you you can have
sex with anyone they have to be
my variety of ugly that would boost his
confidence
who else oh i would i would really dig
deep i wouldn't just go for a commoner
i would go for like korean stars in
korea kim jong-un
kim jong-un oh my god esther the power
the evil but all in that little bobby
lee body
i would offer up that [ __ ] so he
would never give you stale scorpions
you would never give me likes questions
they would be live you would be
screaming no
it you guys thank you so much for
listening or watching
this and please we're we really want to
be the prettiest princesses on
itunes so please give us five stars if
you haven't yet and obviously
we won't be on youtube so we'll have to
be the pretty ones on
and obviously if you're on youtube make
sure you subscribe
we really want to grow our subscribers
make sure you subscribe make sure you
like the video
comment below what was your favorite
topic we talked about
and um don't be mad at esther she tries
her hardest with these foods
nice well um i'm coming to phoenix for
stand up april 29th you can get tickets
for that
on standuplive.com i'm really excited to
stand up
and be crazy and i have a clothing line
sleepover by esther.com
and i have a solo podcast esther club
what else what are you where are you
ladies
oh what's this we have i want to plug
this
what is it it's beautiful artwork
by none other than our auntie that's
what my mom calls
money um and it's her mask
where can we find these ani you can find
these on my well we'll put a link in the
uh description on youtube and also you
can find it in my
links on my in my bio my link tree and
my bio and instagram
those are so funny we're gonna make
annie rich for a week is that is that
the plan
yes guys i have i haven't been pushing
my
masks anymore but they are [ __ ]
hilarious and i love when people
buy them and take pictures and send them
to me i always repost them it's
hilarious
makes me laugh so buy buy these repost
them
it's boardwalk humor
i've got a lot more boardwalk humor
merch coming so follow me on it's
boardwalk humor hot topic
no no it's different because hot topic
is like has bands involved
boardwalk here it's like the shirt where
you're like a fat guy
yeah oh lady i see yeah or like when fat
guys wear the shirt of the bikini lady
yeah vice versa interchangeable yeah or
like you know the little shorts on
venice beach that say like
[ __ ] me on the butt or something you're
like jesus i feel like
can we wear those and then um take pics
we should do uh we should do boardwalk
photo shoots boardwalk photo shoot
with boardwalk humor well i'm gonna be
making a bunch too so
yay ingenious i'll make my boardwalk
humor line
that is a good idea no offense
for you that's good she's shocked
well thank you guys for watching we'll
see you next week bye
[Music]
you